this lecture is an optimization for
machine learning specifically we're
gonna be looking more at methods that
work well for neural networks so the
talk will be divided into five sections
first I'm gonna give a quick intro and
motivation for optimization methods in
machine learning then I'm gonna talk
about basic methods like gradient
descent momentum methods second order
methods next and then finally we'll talk
about stochastic optimization which is
applicable to all the previous methods
that we're gonna discuss so optimization
algorithms are the basic engine behind
deep learning methods and machine
learning methods in general and they
enable models to learn from data by
adapting their parameters so what they
do is they solve a problem of
minimization of an objective function
that measures the mistakes that the
model makes now this can be for example
in classification problems this is
prediction error where you're comparing
your predictions of say the label of an
image to the actual values in
reinforcement learning this could be
negative reward where reward essentially
measures how well you're doing at the
particular task and optimization methods
work by making a sequence of small
incremental changes to the model
parameters and each step is more or less
guaranteed to produce the objective by
some small amount you accumulate enough
of these steps in sequence and you
eventually hope to solve the problem so
just a little bit of notation upfront
throughout the lecture I'm going to
refer to the parameters always as theta
denoted here these will be assumed to
lie in RN this is the N dimensional real
space in neural networks n can be you
know sometimes hundreds of millions the
objective function will be denoted by H
H of so it's a function of the
parameters and you can see over here
I've drawn a example objective function
so up is the value of the objective
function along the side is the value of
the parameter of course if I'm drawing
it in one in this two-dimensional plane
I can only have a one dimensional
parameter of course and in general this
picture is much more interesting looking
in higher dimensions but it's useful for
illustrative purposes just to consider
the low dimensional cases here's our
optimum here's maybe where we start and
yes so the goal of optimization is to
minimize functions of this form
essentially by moving this magenta point
down towards the optimum is as best we
can so you know the most important
example of this which arises in machine
learning our objectives of this form so
you have a essentially what is a sum
over examples I is gonna index the
example will have M of them so this is
an average over those examples and it's
we're measuring the loss between a
target Y and the prediction made by the
network so F here is going to denote
then the neural network function which
takes input X as well as the parameters
output some prediction Y being the true
value for the prediction that we want L
is now a loss function which measures
that is this level of disagreement
between our prediction and the correct
target so this is just illustrated here
again this F is a neural network of
course it doesn't have to be and for the
purposes of this lecture EF could be any
sort of prediction model so next we'll
talk about the basic method of an
optimization where you always have to
start gradient descent so gradient
descent method is as simple as it gets
we so you'll see throughout this lecture
a you know a bunch of equations of this
form this is showing an update rule for
our parameter so at every step we
advance to the next
best guess for the optimum value of the
parameters and we do this by taking the
current value and then subtracting off
in this case a multiple of the gradient
to obtain the new value that multiple
here is we denote by alpha that's going
to also be sometimes called the learning
rate or the step size and the gradient
denoted here is just the standard
gradient when you take the element-wise
derivatives for each element of the
parameter vector
so what's gradient descent doing why why
should this method make any sense well
one way to think of the gradient is that
it's giving you the direction of
steepest descent in in the law surface
so you know in this picture here again
one dimensions well there really is only
one direction you can vary you can go
sort of left or right this is the
direction that goes downhill so this is
where the the negative gradient would be
pointing in that direction we follow the
negative gradient so yeah so so this is
giving us the direction that that
reduces the the objective value the
fastest if you go in that direction now
it's not obvious that that that doing
this should make any sense and indeed if
the picture looks more like this and I
were to start here and take a step that
way I might not actually go down I mean
I might start to go down but then I
might start going up because the
objective function curves upwards like
this it curves up very very fast so this
is bad of course I could remedy this by
setting the learning rate lower that is
the multiple that I take for the
gradient but you know that might slow me
down now this scheme is only gonna work
if functions are ultimately smooth at
some level
you know when you zoom in far enough or
at least continuous so another way of
thinking of gradient descent is that and
this is the way I prefer to think about
it because it sort of leads into the
other optimization methods quite
elegantly is that we start so at any
given point let's just say this is where
we are currently we're gonna propose an
approximation to the objective function
for gradient descent this is a linear
approximation so denoted by this line
here the orange dotted line and here is
this written in an equation this is just
the first order Taylor series at the
current theta and D is the direction
that we're gonna vary and we're sort of
modeling how H the objective function
changes as we vary D according to a
linear model again so this is a line now
for small enough D this line you know
matches the objective function pretty
well I mean right around here it's
almost a perfect match and as you start
to move away as your D gets bigger the
match starts to degrade a bit but so if
we were to minimize this model over a
reasonable region around here that would
give us a D which is this negative
gradient step times some alpha and the
Alpha would be determined by the region
in which we're allowed to move
essentially so gradient descent is sort
of the canonical algorithm but it has
obvious problems problems that are sort
of hard to illustrate in one dimension
but if you even just go to two
dimensions it already becomes apparent
what's going on so here and it's
important to understand this picture
because I'm gonna keep using it
throughout the lecture this what I've
drawn here essentially is a sort of a
two dimensional narrow Valley so you can
think of this as a three dimensional
object where up means the you know the
value of the objective function so
how high are you say in a
two-dimensional terrain you can think of
this as maybe like a hill or something
and across you know so
north-south-east-west
is going to be the values of the
parameter which is assumed here to be
two-dimensional and so I've drawn this
valley essentially where along the base
of the valley there's this sort of
direction that we can move towards the
minimum of the objective function but we
sort of start out here at the side of
the valley and we're gonna if we're
gonna be running gradient descent with
say a high learning rate what's gonna
happen is the gradient is gonna point
this way right off the hill because
that's the direction that goes down the
fastest and that's gonna sort of balance
the other side of that of the valley and
we hit that wall and now we have the
gradient pointing in once again in the
gradient direction which now that's
going to be the opposite because of
course the function goes down this way
so we'll be balancing back here and if
the learning rate is too high these
steps are gonna oscillate wildly and
eventually you're going to diverge so
this is the bad situation well East one
bad situation for gradient descent now
you could try to remedy this by lowering
the learning rate so we're gonna take
these steps but they're gonna be much
smaller and we're gonna bounce back and
forth as we were before but it's not
gonna grow up get out of control
the only problem now is we're gonna be
taking these very very small steps and
once you get to the base of this valley
structure and you still want to move
along the base of it relatively fast
well because your learning rate is small
you're not gonna be able to do that
anymore so there's no good choice in
this situation for gradient descent I
can make the learning rate high I
diverge and make it low converge too
slowly along these directions that curve
very slowly so this can be described in
theoretical terms which I'll get into
now so a a couple of common technical
assumptions that we're going to use
throughout the lecture which have
intuitive meanings which we'll talk
about
are as follows the first is that we're
going to assume that HS Lipschitz
continuous derivatives or aka Lipschitz
smooth now what does this mean basically
it means that the gradient doesn't
change too much as we change the
parameters so a small change in the
parameter translates to a small change
in the gradient or in other words the
function doesn't have too much curvature
so this L coefficient which tells us the
relationship can be thought of as an
upper bound on the curvature in the
objective function and we'll have a
corresponding condition called strong
convexity or of course we don't
necessarily need to assume this globally
it's good enough if it's this is
happening sort of locally around the
area that we're converging and in order
to apply say for example to neural net
objective functions which aren't convex
in general and this function this
condition is given here and essentially
it's saying that the function curves is
at least as much as this quadratic term
which has a curvature of MU so this now
gives us a lower bound on the curvature
of the objective function we're also
going to assume for now that gradients
are not stochastic I can get into
stochastic convergence theory later but
for now it's simpler to think of it the
gradients as computed deterministically
that is without approximations so if you
have those two conditions then this is
the basic bound that you get with
gradient descent
so just to decode this a bit this this
part here is the difference in the
objective function value between where I
am after K steps and where the optimum
is and it goes down according to this
function now this function depends on K
up up here so as K gets bigger this
exponent gets bigger but this
wanted to use less than one so as this
exponent gets bigger this gets smaller
it gets smaller at an exponential rate
and there's some dependency on on how
far you away from the initial point over
here
so the key quantity here is Kappa and
that will determine sort of how much
bigger than or sorry how much less than
1 this quantity actually is we prefer
smaller values of Kappa Kappa is the
ratio of the highest curvature to the
lowest curvature and so this is what is
often called the condition number
although we're taking a global
definition of condition number so
condition numbers usually describing a
property of a matrix but you can also
apply it to an overall optimization
problem which is sort of the biggest
Augen value globally for the Hessian
everywhere divided by the smallest one
and so perhaps it's more useful to think
of what this balances in terms the
number of iterations that we need to
obtain a particular optimal margin here
that is to get to a an error between the
optimal value and the current value of
no more than Epsilon and that's given by
this expression so this is so K has to
be roughly Kappa which is the condition
number times log 1 over the air we like
to achieve so just some words about
bounds are they useful in practice kind
of there's a lot of issues with them
though so often they're too pessimistic
so they you know when you prove these
things you have to consider all examples
including worst case examples of course
real problems aren't necessarily worst
case sometimes they make assumptions
that are too strong
say for example convexity now we don't
really need convexity to prove these
kinds of things often at least if you're
looking at this sort of asymptotic
behavior but it's convenient and often
times you can sort of describe what
you're doing in optimization theory
you know you assume that your starting
already close to the minimum close
enough that the function looks comebacks
oftentimes these theorems make
assumptions that are too weak insofar as
they don't use enough structure from the
real problem real problems have all
sorts of interesting structure which are
not captured necessarily by you know
condition numbers or Lipschitz can l you
no bounds things like this and you know
these these bounds often rely on these
crude measures such as condition numbers
which are only sort of a vague
description of what the function is
actually doing finally and this perhaps
the most important point is these bounds
are usually focused on asymptotic
performance so they don't tell you
necessarily or they don't give you a
reasonable idea of how fast you're
converging let's say long before K which
is the iteration number gets very large
and in practice we often stop our
optimizers before they converge so you
actually do care how quickly you're
getting to that point pre asymptotically
right so I would say in practice your
choice of optimizer should be you know
first and foremost informed by
experience try different things but at
the same time you know you can use
theory to tell you at least help guide
your choices in terms of different
optimizers so these you know theory can
develop intuitions which then translate
into the real world and if you're sort
of nuanced enough that sort of that
works out although not always be careful
about anybody who says anything is
optimal by the way so next I'll talk
about momentum methods this is sort of
the easiest modification of gradient
descent that we can make to have it
perform better so the basic motivation
is you know as we saw in the example of
the
the valley the two-dimensional valley
gradient descent can flip back and forth
when it's when it's when the learning
rate is large so and of course if the
learning rate is small you have the
opposite problem that you don't move
along these low curvature directions say
the base of the valley you don't move
along there fast enough so the key idea
with momentum is that we're going to try
to accelerate along these directions of
low curvature let's say at the base of
the valley and we're gonna do this
essentially following a physics like
equation of how momentum works in in
real physical situations so in
particular you can think of the
parameters like a ball rolling along the
surface the surface is defined by the
objective function and this ball is
subject to the force of gravity so as it
starts to roll along a direction let's
say the base of this valley here it
accumulates momentum this is actually
the best illustration that I could find
on the Internet
unfortunately because you can find a lot
of videos of balls rolling down hills
but what's important here is that it's
hitting the sides of this valley right
it goes up and then comes down and it's
that suppression of oscillation that is
really the important thing that's
happening momentum right anybody can
just move faster but if you're if moving
faster it causes you to go off the side
of this hill you're done essentially but
here the ball is rolling in such a way
that it's not going over that and it's
stayin along this valley but like it
should but at the same time it's picking
up speed as it goes down so that's
that's the idea that we're gonna try to
exploit with momentum so here are the
equations for momentum the basic version
is that we have a velocity vector V and
we're just going to keep adding the
gradient to it essentially well and also
decaying our current velocity by some
factors and we're gonna multiply that
recurrent velocity by some factor this
is you can think of as
friction in a physical system so the
velocity is not just preserved perfectly
it sort of goes down over time but we're
always adding this force to it
essentially and so and then once we have
our velocity we just add that to the
parameters times some learning rate as
before there's also a different version
of that which I won't really get into
but it's a slight tweak of the basic
version that's more useful in theory and
sometimes in practice so returning to
this 2d Valley example again we have
once again this is the situation with
gradient descent where you can bounce
along the sides but eventually you
bounce too much and you diverge or you
take the learning rate that's too slow
or too low and now we're not we don't
oscillate out-of-control but we move too
slowly you can think of this as say in
that video the ball if it never picked
up any momentum it would just sort of
crawl along you know after somebody had
pushed it it would never actually get
any faster but what momentum allows you
to do is use you sort of you go you you
hit the other side but immediately this
vector here is this is remembered in
terms of velocity so the ball has
velocity going this way and then it hits
this side and there's something pushing
it the other direction but that cancels
out its initial velocity so actually the
ends up just going straight and it comes
down here and then it starts to roll
back this way but again it's canceled by
the gradient which is pointing that way
so it's sort of never is able to
oscillate out of control meanwhile there
is one direction which is always
pointing downhill and that's this one
and so velocity keeps accumulating in
that direction and we haven't and that
and therefore we get to our goal in
fewer steps so we can justify this stuff
theoretically as well so given an
objective function satisfying the same
technical conditions as before that is
we have this upper
and lower bound on curvature across the
objective function we have this bound
this is very similar to the one before
except now this term here depends on the
square root of Kappa not just Kappa
itself but otherwise it's identical to
what we had before and what you
essentially get out of this is that the
number of iterations needed to achieve a
certain air is roughly this expression
where we have log 1 over epsilon Bo as
before but now there's a square root in
front of the capless so we've improved
our dependency on this Kappa term by
lowering it because of course this is a
quantity that's that's greater than 1
and now we we've got a yeah we've got
this better dependence so for problems
where this is large this is gonna make
more of a difference to use momentum so
we can then ask is is this as good as we
can do we've added velocity to mama to
gradient descent you know could maybe we
could sort of add some sort of
acceleration term that's also preserved
some higher order effects well it turns
out in some technical sense this is the
best we can do so I'll first start off
by defining first order method
technically so this is the term that
gets thrown around a lot but there is a
technical definition and this is the one
that it was for example proposed by
Nesterov although I'm pretty sure it
goes back much further than that and
it's essentially that the difference
between parameters or in other words
these steps that we take these DS at any
consecutive iteration is given by or is
contained in rather the span of all
previous gradients that we've seen so
these are span just means the the set of
linear combinations of these things so
in other words we've added various
multiples of previous gradients to each
other to arrive at where we currently
are that restricts you to a certain
class of algorithms
and but this is actually a pretty
interesting class it includes for
example gradient descent momentum
methods as well also conjugate gradient
methods which are typically only applied
to quadratic problems although there are
sort of nonlinear versions that also
fall into this category so what in
particular is not included in this
definition are preconditioned or
second-order methods which we're going
to discuss later so given this
definition of first-order method we can
sit we can now ask well is you know is
how well can you do with first-order
methods and it turns out that we
actually now have a matching lower bound
so we had an up or down bound from
before on the performance but now we
have this lower bound which says that
you cannot converge faster than this and
this looks a lot like the term that we
had before and in particular it requires
that the number of iterations to
converge is of this form and this is the
same as the upper bound that we had for
momentum
so in some sense momentum methods are
quote optimal of course this is only
worst-case optimal and although caveat
s' that I gave before do apply but you
know you at least know in the worst case
that you know there is no major
algorithmic improvement that you can
make at least if you keep yourself
inside of the class of first order
methods yeah so just getting back to the
are bound so far we have this worst case
lower bound for first order methods this
is the band that we got for gradient
descent here we have the kappa term
without the square root so this is a
worse worse than we we can get and in
practice gradient ascent does get this
even though it's an upper bound this is
actually a fairly good you know it's a
tight upper bound for gradient descent
and the upper bound for good gradient
descent with Nessarose momentum is this
so it match it matches the lower bound
okay so that's first order methods and
next I'll get into second order methods
so so how are we doing for time sorry
well we've got plenty of time so second
order methods are sort of the next step
in optimization methods beyond first
order methods the big problem that we
had with first order methods was this
dependency on this sort of global
condition number Kappa this in
particular the number of iterations that
we had scaled as some function of that
so Kappa is the ratio of the maximum
curvature again over the minimum
curvature and for certain problems this
is going to be very big say for example
certain kinds of deep architectures
although surprisingly networks like res
Nets actually this number is really not
that bad at all and that's why for
example you see people use regular
gradient descent in resonance with a lot
of success but there are certain kinds
of models for example models that I've
been exploring more recently people at
deep mind have got into certain physics
inspired neural networks that are harder
to optimize and classically we had a
bunch more of these networks around
before people everybody started using
resonance that are hard to optimize so
so in practice you know this might
matter it but it might not and it really
depends on the problem but we'd like our
optimization methods to be as robust as
possible not just break down if our
problems become too hard in some sense
so this is worth trying to improve the
situation and second-order methods do
allow us to do this they allow us to
improve or sometimes even eliminate the
dependency on Kappa and we get similar
bounds but now the Kappa term is
vanished so the the basic
idea with second order methods is to
essentially return to the approximation
idea that we had before for first-order
methods so we were going to locally
approximate our objective function by a
simpler function now before we had a
linear function which was a straight
line now we're going to replace it that
with a quadratic function and the
easiest way to do that although not
necessarily the best way is to take the
second order Taylor series around the
current point so the second under Taylor
series is locally anyway the most
accurate quadratic approximation you can
make to the function and if you were to
minimize this approximation to the
objective function of with respect to D
you get an update of this form which is
the negative of the Hessian inverse
times the gradient so it requires you to
compute this Hessian matrix and take its
inverse and multiply that by the
gradient and then the basic update
iteration is the same as before for
gradient descent you can also augment
this type of equation with momentum as
well and that can sometimes give you an
additional boost it really depends on in
some sense how well you're approximating
H and and and if you're you know if
you're doing a perfect second-order
method in some sense momentum is not
going to help you because you've already
eliminated the dependence on the
condition number but if you've only
improved it a bit you could still get an
additional boost from momentum but we're
just gonna assume that we're not using
momentum for the purposes at least of
the theoretical discussion of
second-order methods although in
practice people use momentum quite a bit
with second-order methods so now we can
return once again to this example so
here we had gradient descent I've just
shown the picture for the small learning
rate which is the one that doesn't
diverge momentum was able to you know
help us get around this oscillation
issue without sacrificing our ability to
move fast along the the base of the
valley second order methods are you know
quite elegant in this
that they just model this curvature so a
second-order method actually sees that
the both sides of the the valley curve
upwards like this models that and it
goes straight to the bottom and then
once it gets here it sees oh this is
actually a very very sort of smooth
pathway that and then in other words
it's quite flat and it's going downhill
at a reasonable rate so I can just
instantly accelerate in that direction
so right so another way to think about
the relationship between gradient
descents and second-order methods is to
think of gradient descent as a kind of
primitive second-order method so when
you're doing gradient descent the
maximum allowable learning rate is one
is up to a fudge constant 1 over L where
L is quantifying the maximum curvature
like before and so given this learning
rate which is the maximum when the one
that we can tolerate you can think then
a gradient descent as like a
second-order method where we start out
by proposing to use the second or Taylor
series approximation for the objective
function and then minimizing over that
but then we because we don't like the
session term it's too complicated we
substitute that with L times the
identity matrix so when you do that
substitution you're essentially
replacing the Hessian with a term that
says the curvature is maximum everywhere
as opposed to trying to distinguish
between directions that have high
curvature let's say the sides of the
valley and the directions that have low
curvature in other words the base of the
valley so all the all directions are
treated as having this maximum curvature
and when you do that well you don't then
you don't get to see that the base of
the valley is actually quite smooth and
in a good direction to accelerate in you
just have to move slowly in all
directions and so L I in some sense is
it's just too pessimistic it's of and
it's too crude of an approximation for
this sort of our altered second-order
method to perform well so signature
methods sound great but there's a lot of
catches and the first one which is
actually pretty easy to handle but is
very important and often overlooked
almost criminally so is that this idea
of using approximations well it has the
same problems that gradient descent has
but in some sense you need more
machinery to deal with them because the
approximations are in some sense pushing
you further so what I mean by that well
if you if you think of again this think
of this example here where are the
Purple Line is the true objective
function and over here we might take the
second order Taylor series and this is a
good approximation to the function
locally but a second order you know
approximation could go off like that
it could be wildly inaccurate as we move
away from from our current point so you
know because gradient descent in some
sense is taking the maximum curvature it
can never actually go to wrong when it
comes to it's it's you know the
minimization of its implicit second
order approximation but if you're using
the Hessian you can go wrong because a
direction that might start out as having
low curvature if you go too far in that
direction it might start to curve
upwards abruptly because again you're
your law service is not perfectly
quadratic so this kind of thing can
happen just you know say for example in
the valley you know we could have right
at the you know close to the bottom of
the hill you could suddenly have this
ramp that goes up and you don't see that
locally until you get close enough so we
can't move too fast with second-order
methods and the key idea then is to
restrict our updates into a region
around the current point but unlike
our methods you know actually worth you
know doing implementing this is gonna be
a bit trickier in practice so how does
this look
well you can start out by defining again
a minimization problem over the
quadratic approximation but restricted
to some region and it's usually
convenient to take a region which is
essentially a ball around zero for our
for our update vector D of radius say
lowercase R now it turns out that in
many situations although there's sort of
technical conditions that have to be
observed but usually this problem
becomes equivalent to a problem where
we're just minimizing globally over a
new quadratic but where we've added this
multiple of the identity to the
curvature matrix or the Hessian here and
so of course we know how to solve this
problem that's just the inverse of the
matrix times the vector times negative
one so okay that's true for some lambda
now actually working out lambda can be
tricky but we don't really need to do
that in practice we can just at least
you know we don't have to worry that
about R and its relationship with lambda
and talk about talking talking about a
sort of each step can be computing a
lambda for our given R we can just work
with lambda directly we can just say I'm
adding this value of lambda maybe it's
too big maybe it's too small and there
are ways that you can adjust this in
practice various heuristics that are
inspired by algorithmic works that you
know that people often use so I for
example use a method called eleven
bookmark card method which allows you to
sort of adjust lambda on-the-fly so
there's another thing about second order
methods which is sort of important to
talk about which is that the Hessian
might not actually be the best matrix
and this I think a lot of people find
really counterintuitive and this comes
up a lot in neural network research
where nobody uses the Hessian even if
you could even if somebody gave you an
Oracle to compute the inverse Hessian
you wouldn't necessarily want to use it
and it's kind of hard to understand that
but I think it's worth thinking about
you know what what makes a good
quadratic approximation to the objective
function right I mean the the Taylor
series the second order Taylor series is
locally optimal right in the sense that
it gives the most faithful approximation
of the lost surface in a sort of a small
vicinity of the current point but I mean
that's not what you want so say for
example you might want an approximation
that gives you sort of a more global
view of the objective function so again
here purple is the objective function
this might be our second order Taylor
series approximation but there is a
different approximation which kind of
gives you a better global view and if I
was to minimize this approximation had
actually been doing much better even
though it's not necessarily that
accurate out here it's still bringing me
to the sort of the right rough area so
in some sense it's capturing more of a
global structure in the objective
function I might also want my
approximation to be more conservative so
say you know for example here this is
the same example on the previous slide
where we had we're talking about there
the trust regions now orange being our
Taylor series approximation but this
green one here if we were to minimize
this one we'd get over here if we were
to minimize the orange one well we'd get
out here somewhere and of course the
objective function is curved up long
before that happens so if you were to
move out here you'd essentially you'd be
you know the objective function now
values now shot up to infinity or
something and that's no good so there
are definitely situations where you
might want to use a different
quadratic approximation to the objective
other than the second order Taylor
series and when we find this in practice
so the most important family of examples
that that myself and others have found
for neural networks are the generalized
gauss newton matrix the Fisher
information matrix which is often
related to the first one there are in
fact often equivalent for certain kinds
of losses and there's also the empirical
Fisher which is a kind of a weird
approximation of the Fisher information
matrix it's cheap to compute but
mathematically it's a bit dubious so
some nice properties of these particular
matrices versus say the normal Hessian
well first they're always positive semi
definite so there's no negative
curvature in the matrix itself now
that's good because of course if you
have negative curvature and a quadratic
approximation that is kind of telling
you that you can go infinitely far of
course if you restrict yourself to a
trust region you solve that problem kind
of but it is nice to have an
approximation which just even without
the application of trust regions gives
you a minimization problem that actually
has a reasonable minimum they and also
you get some you you open yourself up to
a wider class of theoretical results if
you can assume that your matrix that
you're multiplying the gradient by is
positive semi-definite another
interesting fact is that in fact if you
take small enough steps that is you make
the learning rate small enough you are
invariant to any Reaper is a ssin of the
objective function if you use one of
their at least the first two actually
know yeah all three of these matrices
have that property so many people will
know that Newton's method is invariant
to linear Reaper motors ations of the
problem
but these method methods based on these
matrices actually are invariant to any
smooth repair motorisation if you take
small enough steps and that's just not
true of the well it really depends on
how small you mean but that happens much
faster anyway for these methods and
finally and this is just an empirical
fact it works better in practice for
neural nets and there isn't a total
comprehensive understanding as to why
that that's true I like to think that
some of the intuitions given on the
previous slide and these observations
are important but nobody has a fully
comprehensive story yet about this so
I've gone over sort of the common
problems with second-order methods and
in these old ways you can change them
new matrices you can use but there is a
you know a huge elephant in the room the
second-order methods which is just that
these matrices the Hessian or one of
these alternatives that we might want to
compute are huge so in for neural
networks for example you know that the
dirt the prim dimension should say of
the parameters can be in the tens of
millions so that means now that we have
a 10 million by 10 million matrix say
that we have to compute we have to store
it and then we have to actually invert
it and that's just totally out of the
question as n gets into those ranges so
the common solution and the one that
we're going to use we're going to talk
about in this lecture anyway are
approximations at the objective the
matrix itself although there are I
should point out though that there are
sort of a different class of methods
which instead of approximating the
matrix they just approximate the problem
of minimizing the quadratic so they
don't perform an exact minimization and
therefore they don't need to compute an
inverse but though
methods have sort of become less popular
in recent times and so approximating the
matrix is sort of the easiest and most
effective thing you can do so
the first approximation I'm going to
talk about our diagonal approximations
and these are the absolute simplest
things so what you do is you just take
the matrix that you have and zero out
all the non diagonal entries so
inversion and storage super easy right
because now you just have n entries and
you need to invert a diagonal matrix you
just take the reciprocal of each entry
so that's trivial
computing these matrices actually it's
slightly non-trivial but it really
depends now we're getting back to some
of the different choices the Hessian the
gauss newton the fischer depending on
which one you choose there can be
different computational costs associated
although I should say that for any of
those choices there are good
approximation algorithms that will get
you the diagonal but not exactly but for
the empirical Fischer actually it is
quite cheap to get it exactly so now of
course the obvious problems with the
obvious problem with this method is that
it's a very primitive approximation and
it's really not going to give you
anything unless there are obvious sort
of access aligned scaling issues and so
what do I mean by that well if you think
of the 2d value example again you know
if one of those directions say that that
you know the high curvature ones that
goes on that sort of hits either side of
the the valley if that's one parameter
and then the other parameter is moving
exactly along the base of the valley
well that would be the perfect situation
for diagonal methods cuz they could they
could you know you could you in fact the
true curvature is diagonal in that
situation but in general you don't have
that in general different directions of
curvature different eigenvectors of the
hessian
or whatever matrix you happen to be
using are not going to be aligned with
the coordinate axes and so the the
matrix itself in particular is not going
to be diagonal and the consequences of
that can be severe and I'll sort of
erase any advantage you might get from
using second-order methods nonetheless
they are pretty popular so if you take
the square root of the empirical fisher
which is a slight fudge to the algorithm
I view it as a way of sort of
compensating for the crappiness of the
diagonal approximation and therefore
sort of hedging your bets by being more
conservative you get RMS proper Adam
we're at which are actually quite
popular optimization algorithms to use
for neural nets now one step above
diagonal methods are block diagonal
methods so block diagonal method instead
of zeroing out all the non diagonal
entries we're just going to organize our
[Music]
matrix into our parameters I should say
in two sort of groups and then each
group is represented by a full matrix
but relationships between different
groups are not are not modeled in our
matrix and so we zero out all those
entries so in a neural net blocks could
be say for example all the weights
associated with one particular layer or
one particular neuron and those will
give rise to different block diagonal
approximation schemes so these are still
fairly cheap depending on how big your
block is the storage cost is just number
sort of the B here is the block size
I'll assume just for the for simplicity
that all blocks are the same size so
this would just give you a storage cost
which is B times n so you've only
increased your your storage cost over
diagonal methods by a factor B the
inversion cost is B squared times n so
that's quite a bit worse than a diagonal
case but again if B is not too big that
might be reasonable
it's all it's basically just as
difficult to compute this once you get
around the you know the additional
storage versus the diagonal case but
like I said it can only really be
applied in the case where B is small and
let's say if your blocks are the
parameters for an entire layer well
that's still millions of parameters
sometimes and that might just be way too
big to deal with so one method which is
probably the the best at this is is
something called Tonga although to be
frank block Daigle methods in their raw
state haven't really been popular for
many years but this is sort of this is
sort of the go to work on that now one
way you could improve block Daigo
methods are so called Kronecker product
methods they're Kronecker product
approximations so if we start out with a
block diagonal approximation of the
generalize gas Newton or the Fisher
where your blocks are corresponding to
whole layers which are like I was saying
before too big to be treated naively and
then you're to further approximate those
blocks with the special algebraic form
which is called a chronica product then
you get this approximation so what is a
chronica product a Kronecker product is
well it's it's it's denoted like this
eight a times C and in terms of act the
actual matrix that you get it's
essentially created by taking multiple
multiple copies of C and tiling them
over and over and over again and you
tile them once for every entry of a so
you create this much much bigger matrix
out of two small matrices and that seems
like an arbitrary construction but
actually it's sort of a Rises very
naturally when you start thinking about
neural nets and approximations although
I don't have time to get into that
exactly how that happens but you
does and what it allows you to do is
actually do much better in terms of
storage and computation now this is a
type of this is not oven I don't know
why I wrote that must have copied and
pasted it pasted it from a slide but
it's not it is more expensive expensive
to store these matrices approximations
then a simple diagonal approximation is
but it's not that much more so the cost
of applying these okay I see why I wrote
that it there are some circumstances
where that might be true but there are
also some circumstances where this is
sort of not really accurate it's too
difficult to sort of get into because
that you have to sort of get a more fine
grained analysis but you can think of it
as most of the time being roughly the
same now the cost to apply an inverse is
well it's B to the 1/2 times n so that's
just a little bit more expensive than a
diagonal matrix approximation again B
being the number of parameters let's say
in an entire layer so this could still
be you know well B to the 1/2 let's say
if you're if you have got million a
million parameters and in a single layer
you know you still have a thousand
factor here so it's not nothing and this
gives rise to what I would argue is the
most powerful neural net optimizer k faq
its most powerful it's also a little bit
heavyweight but it does optimize
difficult and that's the most
effectively and so finally I'm going to
talk about stochastic methods and so
throughout this lecture I've been
talking about deterministic optimization
methods mostly because it's just easier
to talk about them the theory is nicer
and a lot of the intuitions that you
build when you consider deterministic
it's apply in the stochastic case
partly because well if you take a mini
batch large enough a stochastic methods
sort of looks like a deterministic
method but I'm getting ahead of myself I
haven't even defined that yet what a
mini batches so a so you know a typical
training objective which we saw before
consists of a sum of okay now this
really is a typo these two should be
reversed right so this is a typical
objective function which is an average
of a bunch of individual losses for each
let's say each training case although in
general you know there can be other ways
that you can get this kind of form
arising in machine learning and so that
means that our object our gradient is
the sum or the average of these
individual gradients and well if M is
very large which m being the size of our
data set this computation could be just
way too expensive to always run and so
the idea with stochastic methods is that
we're going to well observe that you
know these eight these individual
objective functions from each training
case are not totally independent right
there you know they say for example
involve a neural network learning how to
make a prediction not every single
training case is totally different from
every other training case there's a lot
of overlap in terms you know the tasks
that you're trying to solve and so and
this is especially true early in
learning so you can imagine in a neural
network you know the first thing that it
has to learn are the basic properties of
the data set the simple sort of
statistics of the images let's say in
terms of their means and their variances
and then maybe it starts to distinguish
between sort of course categories like
cat and dog but it hasn't yet sort of
learned all about the flying
distinctions between different breeds of
dog so
is often you know easier at the
beginning in this sense and therefore
the and the the overlap between
different cases is sort of stronger you
know in other words the the cases are
telling you not you know they're not
that fine-grained information is not as
important and that intuition really does
carry through you do see this in neural
net optimization that stochastic methods
when you start optimizing they behave
very much like deterministic methods so
in this in this sort of in this
correspondence degrades over time as you
as you converge as you start to converge
so the idea was with stochastic methods
is that we're going to yeah we're just
going to take a subset of the training
set so we're not going to take all mm
cases we're going to sample some random
s and they just average over these B
being the size of the set s so this
gives us some kind of stochastic
approximation of the gradient and in
fact it's a unbiased stochastic
approximation so stochastic gradient
descent is then defined just like
gradient descent was but we have our
stochastic gradient in place of the true
gradient and this method right off the
bat actually just won't work precisely
it's not even not even going to converge
unless we do one of the following things
so one thing you can do is you can decay
the learning rate and there are specific
ways that you specific formulas that you
could use here where you know the value
go essentially goes to 0 as K grows this
is a form that sort of elegant and works
well in theory and you prove theorems
with this kind of formula in practice
there are better formulas that you can
pick but this at least is sort of a
simple baseline and every formula that
you are gonna pick is sort of going to
be roughly inspired by this one now and
this is are getting back to my hold
you know theory versus practice you know
there's one thing that the theory says
you should do and practice often you
know by exploiting additional properties
you can do better so another perhaps
better I would argue better alternative
is polyak averaging so this involves
taking an average of all the parameter
values that we visited in the past seems
kind of like a silly thing to do because
you know the initial parameter value
might actually just you know it's just
our random starting point which is not
particularly significant at all you know
but it right but but it's nonetheless
you know as you start to take an average
over more and more things you know the
dependence on that point fades you could
encourage that to happen by taking a
kind of a decayed average an
exponentially decaying average so this
is a type of average which decays faster
than a normal average does in terms of
its dependency on the starting point but
it's the the theoretical things you can
say aren't quite as good or at least the
theory isn't quite as elegant for this
case but this is what people do in
practice and it works better so this
will allow your stochastic method to
converge another thing you can do is you
can actually just increase the mini
batch size during optimization and if
you do this sufficiently quickly people
have shown that that actually gives
conversions as well so there's a bunch
of options here and oftentimes the best
thing to do comes down to you know
really just running the experiment and
trying different things until we at
least until we have a much better theory
for this kind of stuff so stochastic
methods in general are going to converge
slower than their non stochastic
counterparts and this is kind of obvious
I mean you're just taking the gradient
and replacing it with some kind of noisy
approximation so you're basically just
taking
a good algorithm in your cropping it
with sort of noisy data but it's not
that bad so this term or sorry this this
formula is what you get if you do
stochastic gradient descent with polyak
averaging so I haven't defined this
matrix but this is just you can think of
this as the covariance matrix for the
gradient estimates because again our
gradient estimates are stochastic
quantities so they have a covariance
matrix and you can just compute that and
if you multiply this by the inverse
Hessian at the optimum take the trace
multiply one by one over K and then you
add some higher you know order terms
which are going to decay faster than one
over K because again this is constant
the only dependence on K the iteration
number is over here so these terms well
they can matter but this is the
asymptotically dominant term and that
gives you a asymptotic convergence which
for sufficiently large K is essentially
going to scale like this so to get our
epsilon error this is the form that we
get and you'll notice that there's no
log here so before with deterministic
methods we had the the log here here
there's no log so this actually this
dependency is much worse and you can
think of again you can think of
essentially in a stochastic method the
air is going down as 1 over K right 1
over K in our deterministic methods they
were it was going as a exponential
function of K so so this is much worse
in some sense but actually these methods
do quite well in practice and part of
the part of that comes down to various
ways that you can mitigate this sure
make this term small and actually these
terms end up being larger than you think
and so oftentimes maybe your true
optimization is dominated by this
but it won't be true asymptotically not
an interesting thing that I think is
worth pointing out is that it's been
shown that this is as good as you can do
so asymptotically this form is as good
as any algorithm can do ever and
essentially the way you prove that is by
just arguing that if you have only seen
a certain amount of data there's an
intrinsic uncertainty in your parameters
right you don't know what the true value
is because you literally there's no way
to disambiguate it given what you've
seen so far and that intrinsic
uncertainty is the kind of error that
you would get with with this term here
so so SUV with polyak averaging is
actually optimal in a very very very
strong sense but it's only
asymptotically optimal and again
asymptotics are not always the whole
story so you could apply second-order
methods with stochastic gradients and
people do and you know so the there are
sort of tricks of the trade to make this
work now when we're computing curvature
these these you know these Hessians or
these Gauss Newton matrices you know we
have we have the same problem that we
have with computing the gradient right
we don't want to compute it over the
entire dataset that might be too
expensive so the common thing done in
practice is to take take a decayed
average that's just where again you have
a running value that you sort of updates
as you go and it's in its approximate
self as an approximation but it's often
good enough so it is worth pointing out
though that you know based on the
discussion that I just gave on the
previous slide there is no faster method
than SGD with polyak averaging so
asymptotically we cannot hope to get any
advantage out of doing this but pre
asymptotically yes it matters and just
going back to the slide
preview
this term which hides a lot of
dependency in which for example unlike
this term you know this couldn't depend
on things like the condition number and
and rather the pre-conditioner that you
use I shouldn't say condition number so
that the any improvement you make to the
condition number might be reflected here
it won't be reflected here this term
does not depend you get the same
expression even if you use a second
order method and there's no improvement
so this term literally does not depend
on the Hessian or whatever matrix you
end up picking but this term does and
this term can be improved so when would
you expect this to help in practice
well if the the law surface is if the
curvature is bad enough in other words
for example the you know the condition
number might be very big although
condition number is only one measure of
sort of badness the or the mini-batch is
large enough so if the mini-batch is big
you're naturally gonna have a low
variance in other words this term here
whoops this term here is gonna be small
and then this whole thing doesn't matter
as much as it did before in your in
terms of your total error so those are
two ways that it can still help and if
you have a combination of these two
things going on then there could there
can be an advantage and in fact this is
a graph that was produced very recently
which I feel was sort of the ultimate
vindication of this kind of research
so people these days train resonates if
they're doing deep image classification
almost exclusively but you can consider
networks that are say 100 layers deep
but don't have skip connections don't
have bachelor-man have the usual tricks
and this gives rise to a much harder
optimization problem because it turns
out those tricks are actually helping
make the optimization problem easy a
much easier so if you if you have such a
network and you initialize it carefully
then let's say and you pick a batch size
which is you know not crazy
in fact this similar result holds for a
much smaller batch size say 64 then in
fact there can be a huge advantage to
using a second order method like K FAC
versus momentum methods or atom which is
a popular diagonal second-order method
but it's interesting to note that if you
to run the same experiment on a resident
the differences vanished completely
so all methods perform almost
identically and that's what you expect
from the theory if the condition
implicit condition number of a ResNet
was really really good and it seems to
be it's good enough anyway that the
asymptotics predicted before sort of are
the dominant factor and so then it
really only matters how much data you've
seen yep yes yeah so it is it is
typically slower but it it really it
really depends on what kind of second
order method you're talking about so
diagonal methods are almost you know no
cost it would be about half the speed I
would say but it depends on how you
optimize it so people have done work on
mitigating these overheads and it can go
down you know to like 10% slower for
example depending on the different
trade-offs so I it because those things
always depend on implementation details
I tend to not talk about that but yeah
you can get these overheads down quite a
bit and this you know this difference by
the way will never be made up by like a
2x like this graph will go out really
really far it'll almost never catch up
to that in fact these networks are
basically impossible to optimize with
first order methods at least to the same
level so so yeah so so so these methods
can make a difference in certain kinds
of networks but
there is this sort of tension in the
community between making the networks
easier to optimize and just making the
optimization technology better both are
solute solving the same problem in some
sense but it's nice to have more than
one solution and I hope that you know by
embracing these more powerful methods
that might open up new classes of models
that people wouldn't necessarily been
have been able to optimize before so now
I'll just go over some wrap-up and
conclusions for their lectures so I
talked about optimization methods and
how they're important in machine
learning they work by adapting the
parameters to minimize an objective
function and they're the main engine
behind neural network learning we talked
about second-order method first order
methods such as gradient descent the key
interpretation being is a steepest
descent method or also as a kind of a
first-order approximation that that you
minimize locally we saw how this can run
into some issues when the curvature
varies in two different directions let's
say the base of the valley versus the
sides of the valley we talked about
momentum methods which allow us to
accelerate along these directions of low
curvature let's say the base of the
valley and in fact are optimal in a
certain asymptotic sense amongst any
first order method you could propose
then we got into second-order methods we
talked about how these can improve
problems associated with bad curvature
how they can eliminate this dependency
on the condition number or at least
improve it
although coming with a whole bunch of
caveats so for example that you need to
use stress regions or damping methods
for them to work well you have to
consider alternative curvature
approximations there's alternative
curvature matrices and then you also
have to talk about approximations of
those for this to be practical in neural
net training for example finally we
talked about stochastic methods which
use mini batches of data to estimate
gradients and possibly curvature we saw
how these are sort of asked
product ly slower than deterministic
methods but how they're pre asymptotic
performance could in principle be sped
up with the use of second-order methods
and we saw an example of that in
practice and that is the end of the talk
so I think we're doing pretty good for
time I was about 10 minutes early so I'm
happy to answer any questions you might
all have and I also have some references
at the end here in case you're
interested in learning more yep yeah so
oh should I repeat the question okay so
you were asking about initialization
methods what are the optimal ways of
doing that
so I would say initialization is a topic
that's picking up a lot of steam
recently it's been something that I
think was brushed aside for years and
now you've got a bunch of papers coming
out that are tackling this the
initialization method that I talked
about in that slide when I said careful
initialization that's been sort of my
two-year long epic project so it's
actually very very hard to initialize a
deep network like that and have a train
as fast as a regular Network well like a
writer when I say regular I mean a
resident there are you couldn't get
almost arbitrarily complex with this
stuff it's a very deep subject and I
think the most exciting results are
going to come out this year people you
know if you're using something a package
like tensor flow you know you're using a
default initializer typically the
typical rule is to is to take a Gaussian
and multiply by 1 over square root F
where F is the fan-in factor for that
layer and that in almost every
initialization is starts from that you
know that basic point but there's much
more than you can do beyond that point
yeah it so it's it's it's important it's
very important in particular you know if
you're solving you know if you're if
you're trying to get rid of things like
batch normalization or skip connections
you know you can use a better optimizer
to solve the optimization problem
associated with doing that but you still
have to solve the initialization problem
because those methods also as it turns
out were fixing bad initializations so
if you fix both the optimization and the
initialization then you can get rid of
those things by analytic you mean you
can compute them sort of locally if you
know like there's an actual formula for
them yeah yeah they are so they're not
like quasi Newton methods because quasi
Newton methods of course depend on this
history of iterates yeah I know these
these algorithm these matrices are sort
of well-defined at every point the only
reason you'd ever accumulate data to
compute them is just because you want to
get a more cystic livre bust estimate of
them but this in principle you could
just throw out your old estimate and
computer an entirely fresh estimate
where you are yep yeah I mean it's
complex you know there are different
ideas out there one idea that I find
compelling which is a paper recently
published from deepmind
is is that the skip connections are in
some sense making the the network look
like much more like a shallow network
and shale networks are sort of easier to
optimize and that you can sort of slowly
recruit more non-linearity into your
model as you as you go instead of the
skip connection plus batch norm
architecture enables this
it you know you're it's good you'll be
hard-pressed to find a sort of a fully
rigorous story here although I think the
you know the story it things are moving
along in such a way that what I just
said it is almost certainly true
spiritually anyway the the
initialization method for example that
I've been working on follows a similar
sort of principle in the sense that it
makes the network start out very linear
looking and then sort of out but in such
a in a careful way that allows it to
sort of become more non-linear gradually
so you can actually do this analysis
based on kernel theory where are you so
you can actually really see with high
probability what a neural network will
do if you keep adding layers on top and
what you quickly observe is that the
sort of the way that the neural network
sort of maps the input to to its output
is a function that sort of degenerates
very very fast unless you're extremely
careful with how you set the weights at
each layer and the burden of having to
do that having to set those weights
carefully becomes harder and harder and
harder as you keep adding more layers
your algorithm has to be more and more
precise so using default initializations
which are quite primitive you know we
get away with training shallow networks
no problem in a resonant because it
looks shallow enough it's in some sense
it's it's hiding all this depth it those
naive initialization methods are good
enough for a resonant but if you yeah if
you can solve the optimization problem
associated with deeper networks then
these differences are in some sense not
important once you use a good enough
initialization we can train so one thing
I didn't plot on this slide here is that
if I was to plot a regular ResNet it
would follow this orange curve exactly
so we can get these we can get the same
optimization performance now without
without the resonant architecture but
you have to do a lot yep
yeah well so you know the community's
gone a bit back and forth on you know
the importance of stochastic gradients
in terms of you know adding
regularization into the problem it's
certainly true that it does that's sort
of undisputed but there's some
disagreement over how important this
effect is if you look at you know the
the modern convergence theory for deep
nets which actually predicts that the
loss surface is essentially a convex
quadratic within the vicinity of a good
initialization point so really all this
theory that I talked about actually is
applicable because really the function
is more or less convex at least in the
neighborhood that you care about not
only is it convex its quadratic at least
if you use a certain type of loss and
yeah so that theory sorry now I got I
lost your question again was about oh
yeah oh yeah yeah regularization yeah
yeah so if you know if if you are in
that situation where the where the
objective looks like a convex quadratic
you know really there's there's only one
minimum that you're ever gonna get to
right so if you're stochastic method
converges it's gonna find the same
solution as your deterministic method
would have now of course stochastic
methods don't often converge or they're
not taken to converge then you could
sort of ask well how good is my
unconverted maybe maybe the lack of
convergence is itself a form of
regularization probably true but not a
very big source so you know these kinds
of results that I'm plotting here you do
lose a little bit on the test set but
it's it's a few percent and you know I
would like to believe that you can make
up for those differences say by adding
more explicit regularization to the
problem it's a bit dubious in my opinion
to rely on the OP
to perform the regularization that sort
of classically been the job of the
objective function right the optimizers
job should just be to optimize yep yeah
yeah that's very hard I don't think
anybody's really come up with a easy way
to do that yeah yeah I mean you could
try to measure the condition number or
some related quantity I would argue the
condition number is sort of too
primitive of a quantity to really tell
you that much because for example you
don't care about the minimum curvature
really that the function might be
totally flat along certain dimensions
and that doesn't matter at all right so
you your condition number could be
infinity but the sort of the the true
condition number which is the quantity
that only cares about directions that
actually matter in terms of the error
value might be much bigger than you know
it much might be much smaller than that
I should say smaller than infinity so
yeah so condition number is problematic
right off the bat you could try to you
know start computing the eigenvalues of
the Hessian but you know then you get
into the problem that those values might
are you know are describing what's
happening right where you're
initializing but maybe you know the
curvature evolves as you optimize and
then it's hard to predict how it's gonna
look you know halfway through the
optimization until you actually have run
half of an optimization but by that
point you've already starting to do this
empirical evaluation of your method so
yeah no I I think you couldn't you know
you can use intuitions you can say well
deep network the deep the deeper the
network is the harder it is typically
you know unless you're using skip
connections in batch norm and then you
sort of mitigate that oran ends are
harder than feed-forward nets typically
because they basically look like very
deep nets without skip connections so
there's there's intuition so you can
apply but in general it's yeah I don't
have a good answer for that yeah this
one sorry between the between H and
between these ones well yeah this is the
covariance of the gradients and this is
the Hessian it's interesting that in
fact sometimes those matrices will be
equivalent that actually does happen in
certain types of problems under certain
technical conditions so in fact this
term can sometimes become trace of
identity but in general that two
matrices will be different well I mean
so that the covariance of the gradients
is kind of like the empirical Fisher and
the Pyrrhic of Fisher is kind of like
the Fisher which is kind of like the
gust Newton which is an approximation of
the Hessian so yes kind of there are all
sorts of situations where that will be a
bad approximation where you can show
that it's a bad one like so bad in fact
that it'll cause the algorithm to sort
of very reliably fail nonetheless there
are situations where it's good and it
really comes down to the particulars
don't clash more questions um I'll go
over there you were next
yeah well I mean I think I think these
intuitions that we get from lower
dimensional cases have proved useful you
know in the case of you know if you're
talking about difference of curvature
all you need are two dimensions and you
can start meaningfully talk talking
about differences of curvature and then
your then your problem just scales you
know you just keep adding more
eigenvectors into your Hessian and it's
sort of like it's one of those cases
where I really do think you get a lot
from that from the low dimensional case
and in terms of minima well you know a
lot for a long time people thought you
know that the neural net surface must be
really really crazy and it is if the
network is badly initialized and it's
very deep and it's called it can develop
all sorts of pathologies but if you
actually look at the lost surface of a
resident for example or one of these
Nets that I've talked about to a lesser
extent anyway it's actually quite good
and the theory for that's emerging now
from the sort of this neural nets as GPS
literature which is basically looking at
how what happens when you make the
layers infinitely wide is that they
actually predict if you start close to a
good initialization that locally in fact
there is a quadratic looking ball with a
minimum and that minimum is the global
minimum it gets zero error and it's not
so hard to you know see that because why
it would be zero error because you know
of course if you've got infinitely wide
layers well of course of course they can
get zero error right they can just
memorize the problem yep
yeah there can be so so mini batch sizes
as you get as it gets bigger we'll make
the stashed a stochastic gradient you
know better estimated so in other words
the variance goes down and when you're
optimizing you know the reason that you
in stochastic methods the reason you
decay the learning rate or you use
polyak averaging is to sort of cancel
out this variance and so if the variance
is lower you don't need to lower the
learning rate as aggressively because
there's just less of it right so the one
rule of thumb that people sometimes use
is you know you they're that they're
inversely related so you know you if you
double the batch size you might be able
to double the learning rate but that's
not always going to be true I mean it's
certainly not true of a deterministic
method that you can go you know your
learning rate can be infinity right
which is what it would be if you just
keep doubling the batch size and
applying that rule naively but that rule
of thumb holds and sort of a certain
range of learning rates in batch sizes
yeah that's that's that's good insight
and people have developed algorithms
that do that that you know one way you
can view it is you know you're you're
sampling random cases in the mini batch
might not actually be the statistically
smartest
way to get grading estimates right I
mean it's unbiased but it's not
necessarily the lowest variance for
example and and yeah there and there has
been algorithms and and corresponding
theory to describe that or variations on
what you've just talked about I would
say those algorithms are not used much
in practice partly because it's actually
kind of awkward to do that that kind of
data processing because you have to look
at sort of how those data points are
hand you know what the model thinks
about them so you have to run
evaluations and the data pipelines the
way that they're written is that you
know they're they're always like pre
loading data and pre-processing it with
all these threads in the background and
so adding is too much complexity to that
can can be detrimental I think it's an
under explored area though there might
be potentials for a big gain there but
it's so for example the stochastic
gradient you know theory that I gave
right it wouldn't apply in that
situation because in principle well at
least it applies insofar as if you could
phrase what you're doing is a variance
reduction technique then it would apply
but you know if you if you're able to
get magically some gradient that might
actually have zero variance you know
let's say because you just took the
whole data set right then all that
Theory stops immediately working but
yeah engineering wise it's tricky which
is why we don't typically do those we
don't we haven't explored those methods
that much anyway I've been told that we
should stop but if you want to if you
have any more questions you can just
come down here I'll be available for the
next twenty minutes
you
you